[Music]
hi my name is catherine skangas i am a
psychiatrist and a neuroscientist with
an interest in developing novel
therapies for neuropsychiatric
conditions i'm an assistant professor at
ucsf in the department of psychiatry and
there i conduct quantitative search
based neuroscience research to identify
electrophysiological biomarkers of mood
disorders and new forms of responsive
brain stimulation
i led a clinical trial of personalized
closed loop deep brain stimulation for
treatment resistant depression
and i also co-direct the tms
transcranial magnetic stimulation and
neuromodulation clinic
at ucsf currently i'm also a medical
director at nomura therapeutics
where i work to integrate multimodal
biomarker development into clinical
trials on a large scale so thank you
very much for the implementation to
present today
as an overview
today i'll talk about the goal of
personalization within depression
treatment the use of neurostimulation to
specifically modify dysfunctional neural
circuit activity and the clinical trial
that we're running at ucsf designed to
test the feasibility of personalized
closed loop deep brain stimulation and
the initial results of that trial
here are my disclosures
and here are the learning objectives for
today's talk one is to state three
approaches for personalized deep brain
stimulation to identify three important
properties of stimulation response to
understand the concept of closed-loop
control and to understand how spectral
and network features can be integrated
to identify individual depression
sub-networks
so depression is a very common condition
has a prevalence of about 300 million
people worldwide it's one of the leading
causes of disabilities and while many
people can be managed very well with
behavioral therapy or pharmacotherapy
there's a cohort of people who are
resistant to really all standard
therapies
that are available right now
and the poor response rate may be due to
the ideological and hetero and
diagnostic heterogeneity and depression
there are a lot of studies now that
suggest that depression can be related
to alterations in a variety of
biological systems shown here on the
slide
and so it's really unlikely to be a
single disorder and this
as many know led the nih to develop a
research framework for investigating
mental disorders that integrate across
these many levels of information to
explore basic dimensions of functioning
rather than the disorders themselves so
for example anhedonia or dysphoria or
cognitive dysfunction or problems with
arousal or regulatory systems that cross
over diagnostic boundaries
novel
technologies such as cortical or
subcortical brain stimulation are
focused on circuit dysfunction models of
depression and so they're a potential
solution for patients that are resistant
to all available therapies particularly
because symptom dysfunction can be
mapped to dysfunctional circuits and
then specifically targeted
so intracranial brain stimulation such
as deep brain stimulation has shown
promise as a treatment for refractory
depression
in this treatment a pulse generator is
surgically placed in the chest or in the
skull and it delivers stimulation
through implanted electrodes to an area
of the brain so it typically targets a
single structure in the brain in all
subjects with largely a fixed and
constant stimulation dosing and this
approach has been successful in
parkinson's disease and epilepsy
dbs emerged in 2003
led by the pioneering work of helen
neighbor and in open label trials
patients even with the most severe
depression achieved remission and so
there was a really a great deal of
excitement because it was one of the
first treatments that targeted specific
brain circuits
but unfortunately these results were not
consistently replicated across three
randomized controlled studies and so the
figure here that i'm showing
shows a trial of ventral capsule
stimulation where advocacy was assessed
at the 16 week time point
and the lack of difference here between
the active and the control conditions it
may be due to the trial design which is
some people suggest that the 16 time
point 16 week time point may be in
retrospect too early however
inter-individual
response heterogeneity also likely
played a role and so novel strategies in
intracranial brain
treatment stimulation are needed rather
than abandoning the treatment altogether
so personalization of therapy has been
proposed as a means to
um out to improve the outcome of
medicine in general and it's been shown
to be able to do that the variable
presentation of symptoms across
individuals with depression is evidence
that different neural circuits may
underlie different depression biotypes
and it speaks to the need for
personalization within
depression as well
and in this image
from leanne williams work she highlights
specific circuits underlying specific
depression symptoms and suggests that
knowing the neural circuits involved for
each patient might inform our clinical
decisions for that patient and we argue
that this type of personalization is
also needed in brain stimulation as well
and in fact multiple anatomical
stimulation targets have been identified
and shown to have promise in small
studies and these are shown here on the
left and include
areas such as the sub-genial cingulate
and the ventral capsule which are common
structures but now other regions as well
regions within the reward circuitry
the ofc for example
as well and the fact that stimulation
across these multiple sites can improve
symptoms and different sets of people
suggest that personalization in brain
stimulation is possible
so i'll talk briefly about the two most
common dbs targets the majority of work
has been done in the sub general
cingulate by helen mayberg
building on the cortical limbic
dysregulation hypothesis of depression
and she proposes that you can think of
depression as the net effect of failed
network regulation which can be
modulated
from different nodes and she identified
the sub-general cingulate as a keynote
that addressed what she perceived to be
one of the primary symptoms of
depression dysphoria
and she also found that there is
increased blood flow in the sub-genial
things
in both induced sadness and healthy
subjects and in depressed subjects and
that the overactivity decreased as
depression improved
or
naturally or with successful treatment
with antidepressants or with deep brain
stimulation
and she's gone on to optimize the
targeting in the subgenus that using
dti so she identifies a particular
region of the subgenuine cingulate
based on patient's own anatomy that
leads to the best outcome and you can
see here it's the intersection between
these three different white matter
tracks
the second target that's been most
commonly utilized is the ventral capsule
region this is part of the reward
pathway and targets anhedonia which is
another key symptom of depression and it
was
at first used as a region for ocd
with capsulotomy and then dbs and it was
found to reduce depression symptoms in
these patients as well and then was used
as a primary target for depression
itself
and samir sheth's group is another group
that's focusing on personalization it
within dbs
but they're they're using a different
strategy they're implanting dbs leads in
the ventral capsule and subgenual
cingulate as well as temporary
electrodes and additional brain regions
to explore the large stimulation
space the parameter space so varying
stimulation intensity frequency pulse
width polarity and using current
steering to look at the volume of tissue
activation to find the ideal parameters
for each individual patient
so in
deep brain stimulation traditionally
electrodes only deliver stimulation but
they can't sense neural activity so
there's really no way to read out the
effect that the stimulation has on the
circuit you're targeting
but it's also possible to implant
microelectrodes arrays or leads that can
continuously record activity or sense
and that's what's being shown here
is a patient with spinal cord injury who
has an array planted in m1 that senses
neural activity and when one particular
pattern is observed it can move this
experimental arm
and you know later on a patient's arms
own arm itself
so you can see from this a
personalization of therapy includes not
only where you stimulate but also when
you stimulate and with motor disorders
you have visual feedback you can see
that the arm is moving or the tremor
parkinson's disease is reduced but in
depression you can't necessarily
visualize an emotion or a thought you
have to rely on subjects or physicians
reports of symptom severity state at
each moment in time but we can apply the
same principles
so with the addition of neural sensing a
patient's own physiological activity can
selectively trigger stimulation when a
pathologic state is detected and then
you can read out the effect that the
stimulation has on the circuit that
you're targeting and so that's the idea
behind closed loop deep brain
stimulation stimulation is
delivered only when symptoms severity is
high which
may reduce side effects prevent
adaptation and ultimately improve
efficacy of this type of treatment
there are a couple of devices that have
the capability to continuously sense
neural activity so what i'm showing here
is the fda approved and commercially
available neural pace rns system which
is the one we were using in our study
but the biggest challenge for closed
loop deep brain stimulation and
psychiatric disorders is finding a
symptom-specific neural biomarker that
can trigger stimulation and a biomarker
like this has not previously been found
for depression
but there are ways to do this so direct
neural recordings and focal electrical
stimulation have been used in the
pre-surgical evaluation of patients with
epilepsy in order to identify each
individual's seizure focus and map out
important functions that need to be
spared so this is language or motor
control and these electrodes are
typically left in place for about a week
while patients remain in the hospital
and we thought that a mapping stage like
this could also
enable personalization for psychiatric
disorders and we now have trials at ucsf
for depression pain
ocd
and the idea here is to extensively map
cortical impact circuitry at the
individual level and find a biomarker of
high symptoms severity state that could
be implemented then into closed loop
treatment with one of these chronic
devices
so the ideas behind the goal were
developed through
years of research through a darpa
subnets program led by eddie chang at
ucsf and in this research a motion
circuitry was mapped out in patients
with epilepsy to identify novel
stimulation targets
patients with epilepsy have a high rate
of depression and anxiety
and then biomarkers of anxiety and
depression were also investigated and
building on this initial work we
designed a clinical trial to test the
potential efficacy and safety of
personalized clothes with
neurostimulation for major depression
the goal here was to perform the mapping
stage in patients with primary
depression
and then implement closed loop
neurostimulation with the neural case
rns system
we named the trial the presidio trial
and so in the first stage we implant 10
temporary 16 contact electrodes to map
out personalized stimulation and sensing
targets
and then we begin to identify a neural
biomarker of each patient's symptoms
and we remove those electrodes in the
second stage the biomarker is integrated
into the closed loop therapy with the
neuropathy system and then finally in
the third stage we perform a randomized
controlled study of the initial efficacy
and feasibility
our study population focuses on patients
with treatment resistant depression
the major inclusion criteria to know
that are different than previous trials
are
one we require evidence that neural
circuitry can be modulated as evidenced
by a response to ect but not a
sustained response so patients may
respond after one or two treatments but
they need to
keep getting ect to see have the benefit
and then two that we require that
there's sufficient variability in
self-reported symptoms that um and this
is a requirement because we need to
identify the biomarker and this helps us
do that
so here's the overall study trial design
as i mentioned the first stage of the
trial is the implantation of the 10
electrodes across 10 different brain
locations within the cortical limbic
circuitry the patient stays 10 days
in the hospital or laboratory setting
and we conduct stimulus response mapping
to identify the brain target where
stimulation best improves depression
symptom severity and then we also pair
resting state neural activity with
clinical depression scales to identify
spectral biomarkers
of a high symptom burden
so if we were able to find a brain site
where stimulation leads to a consistent
change in clinical symptoms then
participants meet criteria to move on to
the second stage
so here i am showing the results of the
10-day clinical mapping study for our
first patient so during this time we
performed bipolar stimulation survey
across the electrodes in the ventral
capsule the sub-genial cingulate
hippocampus amygdala and the orbital
frontal cortex
and what we saw is is really a diversity
of very specific responses across
different stimulation sites and
stimulation parameters and we just
delivered 90 seconds of stimulation and
we could see
a really
broad array of responses so some
examples of this included tingles of
pleasure with a hundred hertz central
capsule stimulation neutral alertness i
feel less cotton in cobwebs she said
with a hundred hertz stimulation and
subgenual cingulate she experienced a
calm pleasure she described as like
reading a good book with one hertz low
frequency stimulation in the ofc
and it was really astonishing to see
these effects and and through this
experience over the course of the 10
days we really learned the road roadmap
to her brain to the point where we could
predict the resulting emotion or mood
that
would develop prior to the stimulation
itself and i think it was an incredible
experience for the patient as well who
had really been stuck in one state for
years and years and to suddenly have
stimulation that changes your mood and
to suddenly feel relief was just
extremely life-changing for her
so after we
did the stimulus response mapping which
is just brief and and the patient knows
what we're doing we wanted to further
explore the brain sites and the
stimulation parameters that elicit the
positive response was sham controlled
stimulation so here we assessed the
effective stimulation using a couple of
different clinical measures we used a
five-point likert scale combining
subjective responses with
physician-rated affect we used visual
analog scales of depression anxiety
energy and we used the six uh question
subscale of the handy 17 to assess
the short term changes in depressions
vary so results from these scales
across our different trials suggested
that stimulation in this patient largely
modified two dimensions the arousal
dimension and the mood valence to men
dimension
and we found
that there were three different
stimulation paradigms in the patient
that all reliably improved mood but were
associated with different effects on the
level of arousal or activation
and that's what's shown here
you can see um in this
rectangle here you can see arousal in in
dark blue
and
move valence in blue here
and then somatic symptoms in pink or
peachy orange
and then in the second
row of the heat map you can see
the arousal was pink and the moon
valence was blue so you know they while
they both of these stimulation
conditions improve move they have
different effects on on the symptom of
arousal arousal dementia
so two of the paradigms 100 hertz
stimulation of subgenual cingulate and
ventral capsule were consistent with
prior dbs studies and the third was a
novel location and stimulation condition
low frequency stimulation applied
broadly
across the orbital frontal cortex
and the responses to stimulation at
these sites were consistent across
trials ventral capsule and sub-genial
cingulate were consistently activating
while the ofc was consistently sedating
however the effect they had on mood was
state dependent and that's what you can
see in these triangle plots here
for example in the ofc shown in the
first one
the effect of stimulation was positive
and calming if we delivered the
stimulation during a high neutral
arousal state
but it worsened mood if we delivered the
stimulation during the low arousal state
causing the patient to feel excessively
drowsy and the opposite pattern was
observed for the subjugal cingulate and
the mental capsule regions were
stimulation
increased the problem
so we found that the effects of the
stimulation were state-dependent and
while this patient's
primary symptom was anhedonia
because it was anhedonia she perceived
the most consistent benefit from
stimulation in one region of the ventral
capsule
again areas of the one area of the
reward circuitry which made sense
so we also found that the response to
stimulation was dose-dependent as shown
here for the ventral capsule stimulation
on both mood and red and
sorry in gray and arousal shown in red
and we found that the response to
stimulation was sustained beyond the
stimulation period itself and in some
cases even up to 40 minutes for the
eventual capsule
and so together these results the dose
dependence the persistence and the state
dependents together suggested to us that
global stimulation may be a feasible
treatment option that was worth further
exploration and may even
be necessary
so in addition to the clinical mapping
we also did biomarker exploration during
this period so we had the patient
perform 335 vas scales of depression
anxiety over the 10 days which we used
to define two symptoms severity states a
low and a high symptom severity state
and we identified the 15 minutes of
resting state
ing activity that coincided with the
clinical measures where one of these two
states was present
and then we identified the spectral
activity features that discriminated the
high and low symptom states using two
different cross-validated supervised
machine learning models at different
spatial resolutions
in the first model which is shown on the
top here
spectral power was averaged across all
contacts within a brain region so it was
a region level model and here we found
that gamma power in bilateral amygdala
right ofc left subject of cingulate and
right hippocampus had high state
discriminative potential
in our second model
the feature set was defined by spectral
power for each electrode contact so
across including across all the brain
regions and that allowed us to account
for intra-regional variability due to
the electrode positioning
and with this model we found bilateral
amygdala gamma power alone was actually
sufficient for detecting the high
symptom
it was simpler than we initially
anticipated
so it suggests that amygdala gamma power
is a biomarker of the highly depressed
state in this individual
so we found the ventral capsule was a
brain site where stimulation led to
consistent improvement in symptoms and
amygdala was the site of the biomarker
activity we next examine the
connectivity across the cortical limbic
network to determine whether the ventral
capsule and amygdalin nodes constituted
a structurally and functionally
connected subnetwork so that ventral
capsule stimulation directly influenced
amygdala biomarker activity and to us
this provided
further justification for selection of
these sites for the placement of the
sensing and stimulation leads
so to examine the effective network
connectivity we used to vote potential
mapping ep mapping so we delivered
single pulses in one region and looked
at the evo potential in a distant
contact and then we identified the n1
and then to peak deflection magnitude
using standard approaches
um
oh and so that's what i'm showing here
in this first circle plot in a
um it's the directed graph for the n1
and the percent circumference here
indicates the strength of the connection
between any two of the brain regions
and the color here
indicates the starting location so for
the ventral capsule you can see the
yellow connections
pointing towards the hippocampus in
black
high activity strength and the direction
was then quantified by calculating the
weighted in degree weighted in degree is
the weighted sum of significant
connections pointing towards a node and
we
calculated the out degree which is the
weighted sum of connections pointing
away from the node
and
we did this in order to identify the
most influential hubs across this
network and
interestingly we found that the bento
capsule had the highest weighted out
degree suggesting it has strong
connections to other brain regions and
the amygdala and hippocampus had the
highest weighted in degree suggesting
they received connections from many
other brain regions and this is
consistent with what we might
want for a stimulation and sensing
selection and sites for deep brain
stimulation
so we then examine the axonal fiber
tracts that might mediate this effect of
connectivity using dti and this was
aided by one of our collaborators
in neuroradiology leo sugru and we found
that there was also dense structural
connectivity between the right ventral
capsule and amygdala and it was
comprised of two fiber tracts the stria
terminolus which terminates in the bed
nucleus and then the anti-peduncularis
and then finally we found that
stimulation at the contact that led to
the best improvement was 2 plus 3 minus
if when we stimulated there in the
ventral capsule we saw improvement on 11
of the 14 trials and when we looked at
the change in gamma power on the trials
where we had both pre and post vas
scales and resting state eeg activity we
found that there was a reduction in
amygdala gamma on both trials where
symptom severity improved and that that
improvement that reduction was absent on
trials where symptom severity worsened
um due to an alternate stimulation
paradigm or whether if it remains steady
due to minimal symptoms at baseline
so
together
we characterize this complex interplay
between symptoms
mood state and neural stimulation we
demonstrated the importance of a
patient's symptom profile and
interpreting the clinical response to
stimulation
and together these results suggest that
the time a patient spends in any
particular mood state could be a
consideration in the selection of a
stimulation target it also suggests that
a biomarker can be identified and that
we can identify a limbic sub-network
that both reflects depression severity
and can be modulated to decrease
clinical symptoms and this figure here
just shows our approach identifying a
stimulation target identifying the
biomarker and then looking at the
connection between those two sites in
three different ways looking at
functional connectivity
and structural connectivity
and then the direct effect of the
stimulation
so in stage two of the trial we
implanted the neural paste device this
is after we removed those temporary
electrodes the patient recovered we then
we went back and we implanted the neural
paste device with two separate sensing
and stimulation depth leads based on the
mapping study and we use the dti that i
just showed you in planning of this
surgery so that the contacts interface
with those two fiber tracks the strea
terminolus and the antipresent solaris
and then we were able we planned it out
that way and then we were able to
successfully replicate the positioning
of the of the contacts we were looking
for
we then assessed whether we could also
replicate the clinical effect of the
ventral capsule stimulation that we saw
in mapping studies and we found that at
the expected context based on anatomy we
again saw acute symptom improvement
across the majority of trials um and the
patient describes it as pleasurable and
energizing just as in stage one and in
fact we saw the opposite effect with
stimulation amygdala which
was a
control
you can see that stimulating there made
her symptoms generally worse
so furthermore in closed loop
stimulation in addition to the frequency
and pulse width and current amplitude we
also have to consider the burst duration
of stimulation as well
so to do this we tested the clinical
effects of intermittent stimulation
at different stimulation burst durations
over a 15 and 30 minute period
and we found that just six seconds of
intermittent stimulation at one milliamp
was clinically effective
and with something that was important to
us it was below the patient's perceptual
threshold meaning that she couldn't
detect you know these on off state
transitions
which we didn't want because we didn't
want her to go through her day feeling
this the stimulation go on and off
in
we also found that we were able to
replicate the symptom specific biomarker
for the closed loop control so we use
the neuropathy system telemetry wand to
stream eco on in the lab and then we
recorded 10 minute trials of continuous
and medical activity while the patient
engaged in naturalistic activities
this might include looking at her social
media talking to family on the phone
watching clips of movies or even
attending her virtual therapy
appointment
in the lab while we well we recorded her
neural activity we then paired the
neural activity with the clinical
severity ratings and we again found that
amygdala gamma power was highly
correlated with both the vasd visual
analog depression scale and the ham d6
and it significantly differentiated this
high symptom severity state from the low
symptom severity state just as we found
in the first stage
we then implemented the close of therapy
so we we turned her stimulation on at
home such that six seconds of
stimulation would be delivered every
time this biomarker was detected
and um we also found that the number of
detections within a 10-minute period was
highly correlated with the visually
analog scaled depression the vasd and
the ham d6 as well
and so you that's what you see in this
final
graph you see the number of gamma
detections is correlated with the ham d6
as well as the gamma power
so over two months she went home she
received the closed-loop therapy and we
analyzed that data we found that on
average there are 468 detections per day
with minimal stimulation at night
stimulation did interfere with her sleep
if we gave it late at night so we set a
stimulation cap of 300 therapies per day
and this meant it usually stopped around
5 pm
and so that's equivalent to just 30
minutes of total stimulation per day
this is way less than standard dbs um
and about equivalent to a tms treatment
and we found that with this amount of
stimulation alone we saw a rapid
improvement in symptom severity
as measured by the vasd and the hamdi 6
and depression as measured by the madras
and of course we need a randomized
control trial to determine efficacy so
we can't say very much about it here but
we can say observationally that this
subject's modres score dropped from a 33
the night before stimulation was turned
on to a 14 at the first measurement 12
days later and then it dropped below 10
remission
within several months
and she remains in remission today so
it's been um almost two years at this
point that she
when she first
got had her first surgery
so to further then test whether the
closed-loop algorithm triggered
stimulation in a manner linked to the
patient's symptoms and not randomly we
examined then the relationship between
a morning symptom severity rating that
she did at home
and the daily detection count over the
two-month period and we used dynamic
time warping so we could non-linearly
align this daily symptom severity and
biomarker detection count time traces
and you can see here how high they are
this is the purple and the gray lines we
found that the fluctuation daily
symptoms was significantly associated
with the fluctuation in number of
biomarker events detected by the device
and this suggests that
you know it detects change in symptoms
severity
better than chance rather than just
stimulating intermittently
so in summary we replicated the effects
of the mapping study with the neuropaste
device the effects of the clinical
response to the ventral capsule
stimulation was positive and energizing
and amygdala gamma power was again found
to be predictive of the symptom severity
state
and as i mentioned this patient's
depression is currently in remission
she's
doing really well she started driving
again after not driving for a lot of
years
she's taking computer programming
classes python classes and engaged
in going to school with
a goal of moving back into the workforce
so it's really
been amazing to watch this transition in
her life
oh i can okay so
all right so we have a lot of work left
to do
we don't yet know how variable these
findings will be across individuals we
have implanted a couple of additional
subjects at this point in different
brain locations so we don't think the
same biomarker and treatment site is is
going to be in the same across all our
patients
and we also don't know whether the
short-term response that we're seeing
will lead to a long-term response in
major depression so we need um to do
more work but the results are really
encouraging
and it's important to note that this
framework is not unique to depression it
could be applied to a broad range of
neuropsychiatric conditions
as long as they involve network
dysfunction so the understanding of
circuit activity related to pathologic
states and the dose effect relationship
of circuit modulation
could also help provide domain knowledge
to aid development of other novel
treatments for depression many times
these relationships are studied in
animal models but in psychiatric
disorders the relationship between
circuit function and disease phenotype
is difficult to assess without asking
how an animal how it's doing
so
we think that developing these human
circuit biomarkers in small patient
numbers may allow for back translation
to animal models for more extensive
testing of these circuits and
stimulation responses within the which
neural populations are involved and that
this information could then be forward
translated again into larger patient
populations and they re the
unprecedented access to the brain really
allows us to do this
so the work i presented today is made
possible due to a broad
collaborative multidisciplinary team
that includes edward chang who
conceptualized much of the work
and led the darpa subnets project
phil starr ankit kambadi kasama cool and
andrew crystal andrew leads the broader
brain stimulation program in the
psychiatry department
and of course there are other
collaborators bikram rao and neurology
and leo sugru and their radiology
and
our funders as well so thank you very
much
you